this story um really spoke to me the
baltimore museum of art just opened a
new exhibit curated by their own
security guards
the week my favorite magazine reports
the exhibit is called guarding the art
and it's up through july so the museum
asked 17 of their security guards that
obviously are in the you know building
all day every day to select works from
the collection that were important and
meaningful to the security guards guard
ben bjork picked a chair made out of
pencils by artist jeremy aldean because
ben says he spends a lot of the day
thinking about sitting down
well yeah right um
ross the fact that they got to choose to
curate a show based on what they love
just made me feel like it was so
accessible and so doable i thought no
that's a show i want to go see so well
done to this museum
all right uh we have to talk about
bedtimes i think about what time you
guys go to bed martha stewart.com
reports according to a new survey to get
the best sleep you got to go to bed by
9 39 p.m survey respondents said that
that is the optimal time for excellent
sleep and you know millennials they go
to bed the earliest what really really
yeah i didn't see that coming i feel
like you're you're in like a night out
right i feel like the thing i struggle
with with bedtime is pretty much
everything else i struggle with in my
life is i'm such an extremist who's
totally inconsistent i so want to be
that type a person but i'm a hot type b
mess everybody who has it all scheduled
out and is hitting the sack by 9 39
i'm so happy for you i wish i was like
you and i'm just so not no i want to be
that 939 person yeah i do i don't know
about a set bedtime that seems like kind
of boring you got to live life a little
bit you know what i mean like for me it
just depends on how much 90 day fiance
is on the dvr when i go to bed right
funny enough after the break we're going
gonna hit some more headlines um with a
fresh take from none other than one of
the most important talented comedians
comedian pete holmes in fact pete hi
hi
before we go to break what is your
bedtime
well we have a three-year-old and she
goes to bed at 7 30 and we're so tired
that's when we'd like to go to bed yeah
but we stay up for four more hours
because if we don't she wins
and you want that time to yourself
and you have to otherwise you you stay
up all day with her you're playing with
her all day and then you go to bed and
then you just begin again i need that 90
day fiance time thank you
[Music]